♪ "Tonight Show" Cooler Heads ♪
♪ "Tonight show" Cooler Heads ♪
♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
-All right, Higgins, would like
to tell us how the game --
You look great,
by the way, dude.
-Thank you.
My gosh, thank you!
-You're welcome.
-I got a job at Foot Locker.
-That's cool.
[ Laughter ]
-This game is very simple.
You'll each take a turn
answering multiple choice
questions about football trivia.
-Uh-huh.
-Once your answer is locked in,
Two coolers will be carried out
and dumped over your heads.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-If you answer correctly,
your cooler will be empty.
-Okay.
-Your opponent will be doused
with a mystery substance.
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-You answer incorrectly,
you get dumped on.
Any questions?
Anybody?
-Well I was just...
-Great!
First question is for Reese.
[ Light laughter ]
-Okay.
-[ Trilling "R" ] Reese.
-Yes.
-All right.
-How much did a 30-second
commercial cost
at the first Super Bowl in 1967?
-A million dollars.
-Is it...
[ Light laughter ]
Please.
Is it "A," $900...
-Yeah, no one cared.
-..."B," $42,000...
..or "C," $190,000?
-I'm going to say "B," $42,000.
-Okay, your answer is locked in.
Let's bring out the coolers.
-Why would you know that?
-She's just guessing!
-I'm guessing.
-Ugh.
-Ahh!
-Let's see if she was right!
1, 2, 3, dump!
-Aah!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Reese!
-What?
-Oh, my God!
Oh, my gosh, it's syrup.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is this game?!
What are the rules?
-'Cause Reese was correct!
-What are the rules of the game?
-Your cooler was filled
with nacho cheese!
-Oh!
[ Audience groans ]
-Can we see that in slow motion?
-I didn't see the guys come out!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-Oh, my goodness.
-You look like a Lego person!
Okay.
-A melted Lego person.
-Score is 7-0.
-Seven?
-Can't we use fake
nacho cheese sauce?
-No, this isn't your cheese.
-All right.
-Next question is for Jimmy.
-Okay.
-Which of these is not --
not the name
of a former professional
football player?
-Okay.
-Is it, "A," Buzz Nutter...
[ Laughter ]
..."B," Dick Felt...
-Oh, come on.
...or "C," Uranius Johnson?
[ Laughter ]
What's your answer?
-What was it, Butt Nutter?
-Butt -- Buzz.
Don't try to trick me.
It's not --
It's not Butt Nutter.
[ Laughter ]
That's a totally different
thing.
-Buzz Nutter.
-Buzz Nutter...
Dick Felt --
You made up Dick Felt.
-...or Uranius Johnson?
Which one are going to pick?
-Uranius Johnson.
-Uranius.
-I'm going to say Dick Felt.
-Dick Felt, your answer is
locked in.
Okay, let's bring up the next
round of coolers.
-Oh, no!
-1, 2, 3, dump!
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
-You were wrong!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-What are these guys, interns?
-You were so wrong.
-Oh, my God!
-Can we see that again
in slow motion?
[ Laughter ]
-This is insane, this game.
All right.
-Oh, my God.
-Reese is in the lead.
-I'm a little scared.
-I'm going to answer for Reese.
-Next question is
for you, Reese.
-Okay.
I'm nervous.
-Which NFL quarterback's first
completed pass in the league
was to himself?
-Oh, gosh.
-Is it, "A," Brett Favre...
-Yeah.
-..."B," Eli Manning...
-Oh, no.
-...or "C," Peyton Manning?
-Okay.
Oh, my God, I have no idea.
-Take a wild guess.
-Passed is to himself?
-He passed to himself.
-Passed it to himself.
-In the first game.
I didn't even know
that was possible.
Okay.
-This is going to be insane.
-I'm going to go --
one of the Manning brothers.
I'm going to go Eli Manning?
-Eli Manning.
Your answer is locked in?
-Oh!
-Let's bring out the coolers!
-Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
-Let's see if she was right.
1, 2, 3, dump!
-Ahh!
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
-It was incorrect!
-What?!
-Incorrect!
-That's not bad.
-What?!
-Let me help you.
-There you go.
-That wasn't bad.
-You're all clean.
-That's not bad!
That wasn't bad.
-What the heck is going on?
-She got popcorn on her!
-Are you out of your mind?
-Oh, my God this is so much fun.
-Hold on, let me see what was in
the other cooler!
-Air dropped popcorn --
It's air-popped popcorn!
-This is insane.
I know what it is!
-She might get dusty.
The correct answer was
Brett Favre
passed a ball
to himself in 1992.
-How is that even possible?
-Score is Reese, 14.
Jimmy, 7.
[ Whistle ]
Oh, oh!
You know what
that whistle means?
-No.
-Means it's time
for the final question.
There's a twist.
-Uh-oh, okay.
-Thanks for the towel.
This is worth a touchdown,
plus a two point conversion.
That's eight points.
So Jimmy, you can still
technically win.
Okay, this question is for you.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Jim Fallon, this is for you.
-I hope you don't have any more
popcorn, that would be
a disaster.
[ Laughter ]
-Ouch.
Okay.
1943 season.
-Ugh.
-The Philadelphia Eagles
combined with..
-This is my question?
This is your question.
Eagles combined...
-1943, I'm all about football.
-You know '43, man.
43 is your season.
Eagles, combined with
the Pittsburgh Steelers and were
known by what name?
-Oh, my gosh, I know this one!
-Is it "A," The
Phillysburgh Fighters.
-Reese, please just stop
talking!
[ Laughter ]
-But I know the answer!
-No, stop!
Don't let her answer
the question!
-..."B," the Steagles,
or "C," the Pennsylvanians.
-Wait, say it again,
the Pittsburghians?
-No, the Phillysburgh Fighters..
-Uh-huh.
-The Steagles,
or the Pennsylvanians?
-Pennsylvanians.
-That's your final answer?
Locked in!
-Yes, like the Knickerbockers.
-Get on out here!
Let's bring on the coolers!
-I love you guys!
Guys, don't hurt me!
-Let's see who the winner is!
Dump!
[ Buzzer ]
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, it was Gatorade!
-Oh, my God!
-The correct answer
is the Steagles,
which means Reese is the winner!
-Yay!
-You knew the Steagles?
-The Steagles!
-Your champion
Reese Witherspoon,
right there everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is going on?
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with U2, everybody!
[ Band plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪